قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان عدد
الناس الذين تاثروا بالزلزال في المناطق
المنكوبه وجوارها قرب 20 مليون شخص وقال
اردوغان ان اعاده اعمار المدن التي سويت
بالارض جراء الزلزال ستبدا في اقرب وقت
ممكن
مليون شخص تاثروا بالزلزال اذ يقول
العلماء ان الطاقه التي اظهرتها الهزات
تعادل ما تحدثها 500 قنبله ذريه نحن الان
امام احدى اكبر الكوارث التي يواجهها ليس
فقط بلدنا بل العالم اجمع كلما ازلنا
انقاض الاف الابنيه التي انهارت ارتفع بكل
اسف عدد القتلى
81 الف شخص اصيب جراء الزلزال وقد تعاف
معظمهم بعد خضوعهم للعلاج فرق البحث انقذت
من تحت الركام اكثر من ثمانيه الاف شخص
سنشرع قريبا في اعمال اعاره اعمار المدن
التي هدمت ونحن كدوله عازمون على لملمه
جراح هذا الزلزال في اقرب وقت ممكن يدا
بيد مع شعبنا اتقدم بالشكر الجزيل لكل
الدول التي وقفت الى جانبنا عبر ارسال فرق
انقاذ وتدشين جمع تبرعات ولكل الناس الذين
رفعوا ايديهم للدعاء من اجلنا